en tout combien d'argent a été versé
c'était très compliqué de faire ce
chiffre là parce que par exemple
contient une structure qui décide que l
finances à travers cette des structures
nationales ong ou autre et qu'on va
financer
ou que la croix-rouge finances nous
n'avons pas un contrôle sur la
comptabilité de la croix rouge elle a
fait ses propres marathon elle a trouvé
son argent et vient en haïti pour
répondre à des besoins et elle décide
quels sont les besoins qu'elle va
répondre en haïti et la coordination est
souvent très compliqué avec les
organisations internationales leur dire
écoutez nous ça nous intéresse pas coup
face et ça voici notre plan en termes de
santé publique si vous voulez construire
un hôpital ministre
j'étudie conduire des hôpitaux